on the way out i
i felt that i had seen a a small
child's bag overnight bag
and felt like
i needed to see what we could do to make
sure that we tried to get that
child out uh things got crazy
i was unable to see anybody before i
brought that last victim out but i
do remember that and feeling that i had
left somebody behind
when we came out from the bus we went up
the second time when we handed the last
of the victims off
to the eckerd college kids again they
were
having a little bit difficult time
getting them in the boat but
they uh eventually got them all in
except one which was the bus driver
which they appeared to lash to the back
of the boat
while we were down on that second dive
apparently
the coast guard was notified
and they had uh come out uh i think it
was in the white sumac
uh to that scene also on that uh
coast guard cutter i understand and i
only understood this recently was the
governor
uh the governor was in town that day and
really yes
on the coast guard boat that's correct
he was in tampa at that time
and he was notified over at camp at a
meeting and he jumped on i think it was
the white sumac and went down there
that was graham right yes governor
graham yes
and so he was on that site with the
coast guardsman
so he may have heard some of the reports
i understood that
uh we were not uh
enthusiastically welcomed out there and
that there was a complaint that we were
interfering with an operation
so when the coast guard arrived on scene
with the governor
the coast guardsman notified our
supervisor who was in the boat
that it was time for us to leave which
is what we did
well how much how much later did the
coast guard arrive
uh we had recovered seven victims i'd
say in about 20
25 30 minutes
they were probably in the vicinity
already they just yeah they were on
their way down
yeah they were on their way down from
tampa the first divers according to the
times
hit the water at 9 12 and that would
have been the eckerd college divers
the some of the first victims were were
reported
arriving at the hottest pier over in
fort soto at like 10 o'clock 10 04. it's
like two or three hours after the
hit the bridge yes yeah something like
that so
you know some of the people had been in
you know
still there yeah so we did what we could
uh
they did send somebody over we were
asked to leave
which we did and the sheriff's boat was
out there as well
sheriff's boat was out there marine
patrol boats are out there a lot of
boats are out there
absolutely absolutely so we did
as much as we could
and there's no doubt in my mind today
that had we been left alone
that we would have either recovered
everybody or died
trying none no doubt in my mind then
no my doubt in my mind today what do you
think oh yeah we had plenty of air
it was relatively shallow we could have
gotten everyone out
you know we just we wish we would have
been left alone but it was such a
commotion and stuff like you say
everybody did the best they could the
kids were fantastic
and that's just speaking about the bus
you know there was assorted other
private rights there was 35 people total
that
died absolutely falling off that bridge
right and how many people of them were
in
how many of the 35 were in the bus i'm
thinking 20 i want to say 23.
i want to say 23. off top now were the
rest of the bodies
recovered from the other individual cars
or
eventually yes the last victim was
recovered on
may 14th uh was recovered about
three miles east of the bridge that was
the last victim found floating east
found floating yes several victims had
washed up on
egg monkey fort soto park and stuff so
they had recovered all the bodies
by the 14th of may good lord
how do you get what do you guys do after
that day like after that happens you
guys go home
and how do you i mean it's not just
business as usual after that i don't
expect
great budget it was business as usual
after that
was it yeah we we were working the next
day
back out there the next day at the same
at the skyway
oh yeah and for many days afterwards
for me it was a little bit different
because for me
after we were asked to leave i kind of
needed to plan
our next step and find out what was
required of us like you say it was still
as far as our concern an active accident
investigation scene
the national transportation safety board
was called in from washington
they needed some information in regards
to the location of
the debris on the bottom how it
collapsed
you know what it looked like etcetera
when we left that scene that
that that morning we went back to the
yard uh we brought our dive gear down to
the tackle shack and that's where
we rented a camera
yeah 16 millimeter movie camera 16
millimeter movie camera and we got
four 50 foot rolls of film yeah there
was no video then
no video back then four fifty foot roll
film
how much did that cost we don't know
actually i don't think lou charged us
for that
i don't think so he had it you know it
was his camera right
it was a personal camera you know and he
understood the gravity of the situation
and he
trusted us trusted mike the guy at
tackle shack yes
was andy there when you guys went there
no no before
this is lou this is okay this is lou
levine this is uh andy's dad
and jimmy and steve's dad okay so they
uh
we got our gear uh there
he had all the gear that we needed they
took care of us
it was difficult because he understood
what was going on
because four five six months before that
a short time before that the blackthorne
had gone down in the channel and that
was still partially obstructing the
channel
during the accident as well it was still
part of it in there and they had to
re-locate part of the channel to get
around that while they were removing it
we talked about that blackthorne we
spent some time out there
so he was aware of that type of
recovery that type of emotion and stuff
he understood
and called me later on that night and
talked to me and asked me if i was all
right
and if we were going to go back and what
we were going to do
which obviously i knew we were going to
after we had our equipment
we were in contact with the bosses over
at the office the bridge office in tampa
they told us what they needed
measurements
for as many photographs as we could get
we were not much to my displeasure but
for whatever reason we were not invited
to provide any information or help or
input
on the recovery of the remaining victims
but
uh that that's okay we had a job to do
they yeah they had people to do that
i feel like you took sort of like a lot
more
personal responsibility in this than you
were required
yes and no if you read
there's a book that was written about
the skyway
and i think the governor when he was out
there one of his comments and i only
really realized it
recently was that at the time of that
accident
i think it was even at the time that he
was there on that scene his number one
concern was nothing other than
re recovering as many victims
as quickly as possible so for me
yeah maybe i took it personally and
trying to do what i could mike's a navy
man
you don't leave anybody in the water
right i'm a marine
right you don't leave anybody behind
yeah i feel like that's something that
may have been the reason that you felt
the way you felt that overwhelming sense
of responsibility because i think most
people
just an average everyday diver would
have maybe not done what
you guys did that's that's probably true
but you need to understand that
that was our job that bridge fed my
family that bridge and all those bridges
provided leisure activities as well as
work so yeah it was personal
i i i feel at times that i need to
defend that poor little thing that poor
little bridge because it
certainly didn't jump out in front of
that big boat but
it was a nice little bridge and we
enjoyed it so like i say
we probably did but i think people can
understand why i take it personally
i was responsible for making sure that
when people went across it
it was safe right so yeah every bridge
that people go across i feel responsible
for so i take some pride in that i
know mike does sure you sign your name
to that saying that it's okay
now during that time
after that right after that happened
a lot of people blamed the ship captain
for that and i understand from watching
the documentary that there was
a an ongoing public court trial going on
where the government was trying to
prosecute the captain of the ship they
were calling him an
alcoholic they were calling him
incompetent
everything under the you know calling
him everything
trying to blame him for this because
they were trying to find a quote-unquote
scapegoat for this
what was your guys opinion of the whole
situation at
following the crash following the uh
i personally didn't know very much about
the pilot
uh mr larrow i i didn't really know john
yeah i didn't know anything about him so
i really never
dwelled too much on that he was
eventually completely exonerated
right so it it wasn't an issue with me i
didn't
pay much attention to it i
on the other hand
uh when that occurred
and i think that and i hope that people
can understand
my perspective when people say the
skyway accident
is the accident and the victims and the
faces of those victims that i saw on
that bus
and that i still carry with me so i see
it
it's personal i was there right up close
and personal can't get much more
some people thought him i think because
he he did have a rather
cavalier attitude prior to the accident
and i think his quote was
we're going to shoot for the hole
meaning he's going to try to go right
down the center of that channel
between the main piers and hopefully he
wasn't going to run into it
he wasn't sure i don't think in 70 knot
winds
and torrential downpouring rain right
that's right it it
it's it's difficult to say
i can guarantee everybody that he did
not wake up in the morning
and say boy you know what i'm going to
go out and smash you into that bridge
and kill something that's right so
it was a it was determined to be an act
of god
right back when it happened on that day
i probably would have said something or
gotten into a confrontation had i ever
bumped into him
i felt that way for many many years
i have been offered numerous
opportunities to sit down and talk to
john lero
but bob hite a local anchor wanted me to
speak really
asked me to go ahead and talk to him and
see if i could and wanted to
for years i could not i could not
accept the fact that he did what he did
however i can say that i have evolved